it's easy to become numb to media bias
these days so
the ingram angle we're keeping track of
the worst offenders every week
joining me now is ari fleischer former
white house press secretary and fox news
contributor
also here is matt walsh host of the matt
wall show
all right panel we have to begin with
your very favorite
character out there msnbc's larry
o'donnell uh
a little bit of a fawn fest this week
watch
mr president you met and exceeded your
first
100 days goal of 100 shots
uh in arms i've got two of them in here
thank you for that when we were working
together in the senate what i always saw
is you take the most positive things
someone says in your direction
and try to work with that tomorrow
you're 113 days into the presidency this
is the top of the mountain
you're the most prepared president in
history with 36 years in the senate
eight years as vice
president ari i must point out
that the interview aired wednesday night
against our show
and not to be immodest here but the
president of the united states was on
his heir and we still collaborative in
the ratings okay
so the sycophancy only went so far
yeah and you know it just fits such a
long decades-long pattern of the
press doing this for the for the
democrats do you remember laura when
barack obama was elected
and he went to hawaii on vacation the
washington post wrote about the sun
glistening off his pectoral muscles
as they showed him in a bathing suit
then there was david chalian on cnn
talking
about joe biden during the inaugural
with his the lights down the mall
like like joe biden's arms hugging
america
now you've got this the thing is it's
not just the late-night opinion
reporters like lawrence o'donnell do it
it's journalists they keep doing it for
democrats
matt it's always like this you're so
great how great are you but i want to
stay with this for a moment
rachel maddow is not sure what to make
of this whole cdc mask announcement we
talked about earlier but
she revealed some severe paranoia i feel
like i'm going to have to rewire myself
so that when i see somebody out in the
world who's not wearing a mask i don't
instantly think
you are a threat or you are selfish or
you are a covid denier and you
definitely haven't been vaccinated
i mean we're going to have to rewire the
way that we look at each other
matt how much rewiring are you having to
do i read you on twitter and your
twitter account
is hilarious okay everyone follow me
matt
this is i'm actually worried about these
folks now i mean we don't agree on a lot
but i'm sure she's a very nice person
yeah i you know i haven't had to rewire
anything because the cdc has given me
now permission
to do the things that i've been doing
this entire time you know i was gonna
throw away my mask in celebration maybe
burn it but then i couldn't find it
because i have no idea where it is
because i haven't worn it so long
and but i think it's so interesting when
you look how she transitions from
i have to rewire my brain because i'm
afraid to
someone else's bare face makes me afraid
now and then she goes right to that from
there that to we
she moves from eye to we because in her
bubble
you know where she lives she assumes
that this is this is a problem everyone
has meanwhile
in all throughout much of the country
millions of americans have been living
basically as normal for months now and
she thinks that her neurose neuroses is
shared by everyone but it just it just
isn't at all ari
now on to cnn where chris cuomo had
a little bit of spin about the cdc
director's performance
doing the job too well you're playing it
too safe
that is the criticism uh that you need
to
be more generous and what people can do
once they get vaccinated
all right doesn't this get to the
framing of these interviews that we were
just speaking about
how they put this together
great word laura the framing and the
framing gives away so much about media
bias
you know it's not that they're playing
it too safe as they're playing it
totally confusing
i remember watching on cnn just last
week an interview that a different
anchor did with the
head of health and human services who
said you know the numbers are coming
down we really don't need to be wearing
masks much anymore but when you're
outside you should wear a mask
and i was watching what did you just say
you just contradicted yourself your word
salading
and the anchor never followed up he
never said yes or no do we have to wear
masks outside
you know the cdc just backed into this
decision to
say you don't have to wear masks indoor
or outdoor anymore because i think they
couldn't keep up with their own
confusion
and thank goodness they did it i'm glad
they said it and i want to live that way
i hope everybody does